[Musica]
per capire appieno il mio discorso che
sarà molto scientifica e molto tecnico
vorrei dovete capire questa slide
no vero facciamo che faticano e a
capirla che se l'abbiamo fatta quindi se
avete avuto una reazione del genere è
normalissimo
ed è qui che vorrei pure puntare perché
il mio gruppo il kristen lab è nato per
rendere la scienza è tutta la parte
scientifica della scuola più facile e
più divertente
per fare ciò abbiamo ci siamo posti tre
punti l'immediatezza dei nostri
contenuti che devono essere belli da
vedere ma anche molto stretti perché si
sa dopo un po un video scientifico
annoia poi abbiamo una grande
flessibilità perché vogliamo far sì che
il nostro progetto sia per tutti quindi
anche va bene sia dal liceo scientifico
dal liceo linguistico
poi passiamo alla qualità dei contenuti
un aspetto molto fondamentale che
secondo noi rende anche il tutto più
facile divertente da vedere
noi vogliamo condividere la scienza cosa
vuol dire condividere
vi faccio una domanda quanti di voi
hanno dato lo smartphone negli ultimi
cinque minuti appunto noi sfruttando
questa dipendenza
vogliamo far sì che la scienza vi venga
mostrata e anche gli venga voglia di
guardarla sfruttando youtube
un'applicazione per telefono anche un
sito internet potete usufruire dei
nostri servizi e chi siamo
siamo un gruppetto di liceo e del liceo
scientifico mai chiusi che hanno avuto
un in questa idea il fratello da un
concorso il concorso el'amat for science
challenge indetta da una azienda
farmacologica molto famosa e che
prevedeva la creazione di dieci
esperimenti
da qui è nata l'idea perché non prendere
questi esperimenti accessibili a tutti
perché non farli non far sì che la gente
di venga voglia di guardare di
informarsi da qui abbiamo iniziato a
pensare ed è venuta fuori da di creare
un sito cioè raccolto da tutte le schede
di preparazione degli esperimenti
la cosa principale che vorrei
sottolineare che queste schede sono
una linea guida su come fare un
esperimento quindi chiunque può
aggiungici del suo adattare
l'esperimento anche alle proprie
possibilità
poi abbiamo creato un canale youtube che
racchiude tutto quello che facciamo
quindi esperimenti video esperienziali o
anche che abbiamo fatto in posti
scientifici come per esempio una gita al
cern abbiamo fatto e su questo punto noi
ci focalizziamo molto perché pensiamo
che la parte video sia una parte
fondamentale del nostro progetto e da
qui abbiamo cercato di aumentare la
qualità integrando tecniche di
videomaking il processo per la creazione
di un nostro video è molto scrupoloso
partendo dalla parte di scrittura dove
creiamo un vero e proprio copione per
ogni nostro video quindi ci immaginiamo
le scene studiamo la scaletta e creiamo
anche un copione da seguire
poi passiamo alla parte di ripresa vera
e propria dove sfruttando diverse
inquadrature o anche telecamere le
specifiche come per esempio un ago pro
attaccata al petto di chi esegue
realmente l'esperimento cerchiamo di
coinvolgere appieno il fruitore
nella nostra esperienza nella fase di
montaggio poi cerchiamo di coincidere
tutto quindi di riassumere il più
possibile quello che abbiamo fatto in
modo tale che venga un'esperienza corta
ma comunque ricca di contenuti e poi
ogni tanto quando ci capita
passiamo a parte un po divertente dei
nostri progetti dove inseriamo dei
piccoli specie speciale fx che possono
essere un esplosione perché ovviamente
in laboratori non possiamo farla oppure
sistemiamo delle cose possiamo anche
usarla per esempio per rendere al meglio
una reazione in laboratorio che non ci è
venuta bene abbiamo anche delle nuove
frontiere che possono essere riprese a
360 gradi un esperimento
questo ci consente anche di immergere
ancora di più chi sta affluendo dai
nostri del nostro progetto
poi passando anche a un qualcosa che
stiamo sviluppando vede recentemente le
riprese in 3d ovviamente non possiamo
farle con una telecamera del genere che
costa un bel po di soldi ma ci stiamo
insegnando creando un piccolo righe che
consiste in due telefoni messi insieme
con un po di cartone è un'applicazione
che li tenga insieme che li faccio
lavorare all'unisono da qui possiamo
ottenere una ripresa stereoscopica e
così creare in effetti un esempio
potrebbe essere il pendolo in fisica
questo esperimento potrebbe risultare
molto di più se noi siamo al centro
dell'esperienza e vediamo per il pendolo
arrivarci verso di noi è un modo come un
altro per poter aumentare di coinvolgere
di più chi sta guardando il video qui
sembra che ci siamo sbagliati con la
slide ma in realtà è la nostra cure
istanbul up cioè un'applicazione che
stiamo sviluppando è che racchiuderà
tutto il materiale che vi ho appena
spiegato quindi la parte scritta e la
parte video ma anche dei tool da
utilizzare il laboratorio come possono
essere fogli di calcolo ma anche un
enciclopedia su tutti la strumentazione
di laboratorio o raccoglitore di segnali
di pericolo che non bastano mai quando
si parla lavora con l'acido noi terremo
ci teniamo a sottolineare anche che
questa qui è un'idea aperta a tutti
oltre che nella nostra scuola noi
speriamo che un giorno magari potremmo
trovare un altro stand lab in un'altra
scuola
chiunque per noi potrebbe già da oggi
iniziare a progettare esperimenti
comunque rendere disponibile a tutti
quello che fanno in laboratorio perché
sembra una cosa buona e giusta
poi quello che vogliamo dire anche che
la scuola non è solo un posto lugubre
dove si va a studiare ma è la scuola
uguale innovazione durante l'arco di
tutto quello che abbiamo fatto ci siamo
accorti che ci siamo divertiti a fare
questo progetto e che abbiamo anche
consentito alla scuola di progredire
anche raggiungendo risultati importanti
come potete vedere prima nel concorso
questa qui invece è la nostra
la frase che ci ha guidato lungo tutto
il nostro percorso e che ci rappresenta
più di tutte la conoscenza non di
nascere michael essere condivido per
finire poi abbiamo preparato una piccola
chicca da mostrare come per la prima
volta al ted che sarebbe un piccolo
video che era chiudere la nostra essenza
nel nostro stile
ci illustrerà cosa abbiamo fatto pregate
[Musica]
luminosi né lavorazione gli stess altri
comunque questa è la possa fondere
[Musica]
inoltre qui abbiamo piena è chi si
occupa del montaggio video con
attenzione
[Musica]
con questa si mostra subito
beh quando la maria veloci progetti si
potrebbe dire che ci facevano in quattro
se entra a far danni
ecco qui questo è tutto mi raccomando
vdc trovare sul nostro canale youtube e
ce l'ho fatta internet
no
[Musica]
era
[Applauso]